[Music]
business contribution to sports and or
community sponsored by the Pahlavi group
mental health muscle mental health
muscle are a community not-for-profit
organisation that look at raising
awareness of mental health issues within
society utilizing Fitness and the gym
mental health muscle reside in Newton
Abbot running events to educate
communities encourage interactions and
communications through their projects
they raise money for individuals to be
fully funded to attend gyms and fitness
centers in addition mental health muscle
are also starting to build a support
network in America and Europe so they
can grow and develop in the future see
sports southwest sue and Tim Cox at Sea
Sports Southwest have become an integral
part of the Timnath community over the
past eleven years promoting healthy
active lifestyles and encouraging all to
get involved in watersports
they also promote seaside safety and are
heavily involved in local events such as
Timnath regatta with an upcoming focus
for more women on the water they're
constantly striving for equality and
demonstrating the accessibility and
positive effects of water sports as an
active lifestyle choice
[Applause]
Sherwood's weather history of making
voluntary contributions to the Newton
Abbot community sure words building
engineers have carried on their local
support in 2017
a great supporter of the Southwest youth
games share words have once again
contributed as sponsors supported events
and provided office space for the
charity business owners Joe and Kevin
Sherwood and even parents of competitors
share words are also a member of Newton
Abbot Rotary Club enabling them to reach
different groups in the town through
event organization and charity
collections
[Music]
you